[موسيقى]
تحيه طيبه وكل عام وانتم بالف خير العالم
العربي الى اين
الا يزداد الوضع المعيشي في العديد من
البلدان سوءا يوما بعد يوم الا يدق الجمعه
الابواب الا يشهد الاردني
95% من السوريين تحت خطر الا تنهار العمله
المصريه تباعا وترتفع الاسعار بشكل جنوني
الا يعيش الكثير من اللبنانيين على
المساعدات الا يواجه السودانيون ازمه
معيشيه طاحنه تزداد ضراوه اليس الوضع في
تونس واليمن على كف عفريت الا يخاطر
الشباب بحياتهم في عرض البحار هربا من
الاهوال الاجتماعيه في شمال افريقيا اليست
الانظمه مسؤوله عن هذا لانهيار الكبير
الذي ينذر بكوارث خطيره
لكن في المقابل الا تواجهه اوروبا نفسها
ازمات معيشيه متلاحقه الا تعاني اعلى
انواع التضخم منذ عقود اليست الازمه
المعيشيه عالميه بامتياز الم تفعل جائع
كورونا فعلها بالعالم اجمع الا يلعب ضباع
العالم الكبار الا عيب اقتصاديه وماليه
شيطانيه تسحق العديد من دول المنطقه الا
تتحمل امريكا وغيرها مسؤوليه لانهيار
المعيشي في الشرق الاوسط اسئله اطرحها على
الدكتور محمد هنيد الاستاذ في جامعه
السوربون الفرنسيه وعلى المحلل السياسي
والاقتصادي الدكتور عبد اللطيف نبدا ونقاش
بعد الفاصل
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم
في برنامج الاتجاه المعاكس دكتور
الخليج
العالم العربي لنقل يعني كل الدول العربيه
يعني لا تخفى على احد الى اين خاصه نحن في
بدايه عام جديد هذا العام ماذا يحمل الى
اين ذاهبون
نلحظه الان هو ان النظام الرسمي العربي
وصل الى اخر اطواره يعني نهايه النظام
الرسم العربي الذي نعرفه منذ نعم انتهى
ثوره
من مجاعات لن ننسى انه في اليمن منذ 2015
2016 حسب التقارير منظمه الدوليه برنامج
الغذاء العالمي مات 85,000 طفل يمني في
ثلاث سنوات من 15 ل18
85 طفل يمني لم يسمع بهم احد او كان
الاعلام يعني مساله المشاعات والموت
موجوده نحن في دي هاقول اسمها قائد ذاهب
اليها لماذا يقول لك نهايه طور هذا الطور
من النظام الاستبداد او النظام الرسمي
العربي الذي تشكل على اكذوبه الدوله
الوطنيه وهم السياده والاستقلال في
الخمسينيات يعني سواء بالنسبه للانظمه
الوراثيه التي صمدت اكثر افضل ومنها دول
الخليج او الجمركيات العسكريه هذه الانظمه
الامنيه والانقبات النظام الرسمي العربي
عاش على اكذوبه هاته عدونا في الخارج
سنبني السياده
فوق صوت المعركه والصهيونيه والامبرياليه
والمؤامره الخارجيه لكن لم يحدث شيء اليوم
وصلت الشعوب الى انها تجوع في بطونها لا
نجد ما ناكل الاضرابات في كل مكان هذا هو
الطور النهائي والاخير النظام ما سيحدث
بعده لا نعلم ما سيحدث بعده لكنه سيكون
كارثيا للاسف الشديد وارجو ان اكون مخطئا
النظام الرسمي العربي جاءته فرص كثيره
ليصبح نفسه بنفسه من داخل نفسه الثورات
العربيه كانت اداء قالت لنظام الرسم
العربي انتهاء مشروعك الاستبدادي ولابد من
حريات فصل السلطات الحقوق العداله
الاجتماعيه لقمه عيش نظيفه كرامه وطنيه
بشغل حريه لكن لم يسمع بذلك وقال انا
ساواصل لانه يتحرك حسب امر الوكيل الخارجي
لكن من الداخل اكلت العصابات كل شيء
تقريبا في سوريا في تونس في الجزائر في
المغرب في مصر في ليبيا دمرت كل شيء ماذا
حدث خلال الثورات هناك رفض النظام الرسمي
العربي اني يعني يذهب الى اصلاحات جذريه
عميقه فقام بيقمع همم الثورات وهذه المطر
خرجت سوريا من المعادله دمر نفسه الاسد او
نحرق البلد واحرق البلد في مبارك العسكر
محكمه واونه بيدكم ابادهم وما زال يحكم
والدولار سيذهب الى ابعد من 20 و30 في
ليبيا دمر دمروا يعني المشهد الليبي رغم
انهم لا يتفقون الى اليوم رغم كل ثرواه
ليبيا الى الوصول الى حل سياسيون الازمه
فالذي حدث هو سببه اساسا بنسبه كبيره جدا
الداخل هو المسؤول لكن الطاغيه العربي
وادوات الطغاه العرب دائما يصدرون المشكله
الى الخارج لماذا يحقق هذا هدفين اساسيين
للطاغي اولا يظهره بمظهر الضحيه لانه
مؤامره مو ابو عبد الناصر ويعني عبد
الناصر صدام الاسد القبضه في كلهم نظريه
مؤامره يقولون والله الخارج يتامر علينا
ونحن الله يصبح المستمر حيه لكن يحقق هدف
ثاني وهذا هو الاساسي وهو انه يسيطن كل
نفس معارض يطالب حريه ديمقراطيه عداله شغل
كرامه وطنيه ويصبح كل من يطالب بهذه
الحقوق متامر لصالح الخارج هو يتخابر مع
الخارج
الحقيقي
همم المعارضه التي لا تستطيع ان تتحدث
اليوم وصلنا الى نهايه هذا الطريق انتهى
المعارضات العربيه عندما تسلمت السلطه في
مصر في تونس في سوريا في سوريا اقل تونس
ليبيا الى غير ذلك لم تحقق ما كانت تنادي
به من امكانيه يعني مرحله انتقاليه تمر
بها الى دوله وطنيه دوله حقوق وحريات
الغير ذلك قامت بالتسارع واعاده انتاج
الاستبداد اذا وصلنا الى هذا المفترق
الطرق ان المواطن العربي او الشعب العربي
لا يحلم بغير الهجره والهرب قوارب الموت
التي تراها والتي تغادر ضفاف المتخصصه من
شمال افريقيا شمال افريقيا لم يبقى ولو
تفتح اوروبا غدا حدودها وتحت تاشيره والله
لن يبقى احد الا من يزحف على بطنه للذهاب
الى اوروبا لماذا لان انتهى كل امل في
امكانيه العيش كم مواطن لديه حقوق لديه
واجبات لديه شغل لديه كرامه لديه حريه كما
قال ابن خلدون وهذي كل سنه الظلمه مؤذنين
بخراب العمره وهذا ما حدث اليوم نقف على
اطلال خرب العمران والطور الموالي لهذا
الطور البشر طيب بس قبل ما اذهب الى
الدكتور البعض كان يعتقد ان العام الماضي
عام 22 كان اسوا الاعوام ويعتقد ان
الانفراج سيح اذا صح التعبير في هذا
العامل الحالي 23 انت تقدم صوره على عكس
تماما ارجو من الله ان اكون مخطئه لكن ما
نذهب اليه انما سنترحم على 2022 و21 و20
هو يتدخل كمعدل كموجه لكن خارج لا يتدخل
بسرعه الهدف الاول انه يظهر الديمقراطي
يدافع عن حقوق الانسان ويساعد وكل
الاكاذيب الغرب
ثم يظهر ان المجرم القاتل السفاح والنظام
الاستدلال العربي
الى غير ذلك يعني الغرب فقط معدل يتدخل
لمشاريع لكن للادوات المنفذه هي ادوات
داخليه هي نحن نحن هم سبب خراب انفسهم يا
سلام دكتور
واضح اتفضل يعني اولا تحيه لكم الساده
المشاهدين الكرام طبعا نحن ما في عندنا
عمليه انكار انه ما في ازمات داخليه
بالوطن العربي لكن الاصل هي الهيمنه
الخارجيه على هيدي الانظمه والبلاد
العربيه
في دوله بالعالم حدث فيها حدث بلبنان
الدوله تسرق المودعين في المصارف لم يحدث
الكل الناس اللي بتتعاطى بالتجارات او
بحياتها الاجتماعيه اموالها بالبنوك امر
واحد جاء لحاكم مصرف لبنان من سفيره الشؤم
عنا شيتا انه ما بقى تعطي ولا فرنقله
الناس
المصالح
الامريكيه موجوده بالبنك المركزي وهي تدير
اللعبه يوميا على مدار الساعه
احنا مش عملنا همم
موجوده
الرياض والسلام
من عده دول اوروبيه قضائيه مطلوب قضائيا
مين بيمنع القضاء عنده
السفيره الامريكيه ممنوع حدا يقرب انه اذا
تتمته
تصادر وتحجز كل اموال لبنان الذهبيه وغير
الذهبيه الى هذا الحد ابدا فهيد مين اللي
مسؤول عنه كل يوم البيان اييي صادر عن
البنك المركزي طلع الدولار
20,000 25,000 بيفرق ما بين طلعه ونازله
خربت بيوت العالم
لكن ادوات الداخليه
قول اللي قطع الطائرات يعني هؤلاء هؤلاء
لماذا لم يحاسب منهم احد
النظام اللي عنا اللي اورثتنا اتفاقيه
الطائف هو جعل المواطن اللبناني يفقد
مواطنيته جعلته يعيش ضمن بوتقه مزرعه
ممنوع انت تتوظف اي وظيفه بلبنان اذا كنت
تابع لطايفه معينه
لحد هلا السفير السعودي ببيروت جمع الدنيا
كلها واحد يقرب على الطائف
بس بس بس بس بس بس ما يكون الموضوع لبناني
بس خليني اسالك سؤال
تربط البحر الابيض
رجع جاء من هو اسوء اذا بدك تقول عنه في
البعد بقول انه لا احسن
ما انت مش عم تسمح باي شكل من الاشكال انه
يصير في اي حركه النهضه كان عندهم مصر سوف
الطيارات سوق 35 مع روسيا وخلصت السفر
منعتها امريكا لا لا تاخذ سفره طيران لانه
في مخطط لضربه جيش المصري الذي استهدف
يوميا بسينا روح على تركيا
مع سوريا الا ما هنالك فاذا هذه المؤسسات
الامريكيه الحكم اللي هي عم تتحكم بهذا
المفاصل طبعا لها ناس جوه طبعا الاطراف
[موسيقى]
باي جرم بحجه الوضع الطائفه بس خليني في
الوضع الاقتصادي الوضع المعيشي الان الان
انهيار حصل في لبنان تحدثت عن انهيار
الحاصل في لبنان هل ينسحب هذا المشهد على
بقيه كيف اعطيني امثله يعني روح على
الفريق السوداني حكم بالعراق للسمائي له
يومين بلش يعمل عمليه اصلاح باتجاه مصادره
الاموال الفاسدين اللي كانوا بالحكومه هلا
تم الع- اللعب بالدولار مباشره الدينار
بالدينار العراقي مباشره بين انخفاض هيدي
العمله والتهديد بمظاهرتين من اجل مانع
وصول طريق الحرير الى العراق اللي كان سبب
باسقاط حكومه عبد المهدي واللي قال عنها
مباشره بمقابله خاصه انه تم تهديد مباشره
من الاداره الامريكيه اذا بواصل ال- ال-
الاتفاقيه مع الصين بخصوص
طريق الحرير يعني الشعب السوري
على لبنان اخر شيء ممنوع نحنا نتحول نحو
الشرق نهائيا
من ايران فيول ونفط مجاني مع شركه كهرباء
جاء من روسيه
الاداره الامريكيه هي التي تضغط بمنع هيدا
اللوائح من اجل من اجل تسخير المنطقه التي
تكون بخدمه المشروع صهيوني خليك تفضل هذا
طبيعي جدا يعني هل تعرف انت دوله بما فيها
الصين ما عندها عداوات ومن يريد يدمرها
الصين وما ادراك وعليها مؤامرات يعني
ترامب نفسه ما في انسان ما عنده اعداء في
الخارج هذا طبيعي يا اخي البدن حتى بدل
الانسان في خلايا تدافع تضعف الخلايا
الداخليه يموت يعني تدخل عليه الجراثيم
حتى قانون الفيزا يقول ذلك يعني اللي صار
لا يغير الله ما بقوم حتى يغيروا ما بانفس
اللي حدثته استاذنا انه في عندنا احنا
قابليه انه اخذنا قابله لذلك هناك تراكمات
لدول العصابات العائلات التي امتلكت
الاقتصاد والسلطه والثروه وكل شيء هي التي
تحدد انهيار الجنيه المصري عندما انهيار
جنيه
ارجل الدجاج
لانه المؤامره الامريكيه المؤامره
الامريكيه تتعامل على الجمل حتى على قطر
يا اخي هل القطره نقاط القطري الشحات في
بلده والاماراتي او الكويتي نحن بالنسبه
الينا هناك انظمه فاسده انتهتروحيتها
وكونت من التراكمات انها اكلت من العظم
اكلت اللحم واليوم وصلت للعظم انتهى
الموضوع ما عندك ما تسرق في البلد يعني ما
حدث في لبنان حتى انه المواطن ما يجد في
المصرف امواله بان العصابات دارك حتى
العام اموال البنوك سرقوا كل شيء فما
عندنا ما نسرق الان
الموضوع مش انه في دوله فيها ناس عندها
قابليه ودوله في ناس ما في عندك قابليه
المشكله انت وقت بتضرب حصار على بلد
وممنوع تخليه يتعامل تجاريا باي منطقه
بالعالم
شو قادر تعمل انت ولا الدكتور ولا انا اخذ
البلد وقت اللي اميركا محاصره المنطقه
كلها سوا ما عم تخليك تتحرك شو بدك
نجحوا عملوا كاس العالم
في الدول ماشي تحت السلطه بشكل ما بدها
تعادل السلطه الامريكيه والاداره
الامريكيه ومشاريع امريكا في المنطقه وفي
الدول الثانيه اللي هي بعدها لحد هلا انا
بعطيك ريتشارد دوبلاك السيناتور الامريكي
بدون يعني عم يحكي بمقابله تلفزيونيه
وابعث لك شفت الفيديو اكيد بيقول نحن قبل
الازمه بسوريا كل سوريا عندها فائض امحوا
معلوم قبل الازمه السوريه عند السفر
مديونيه صفر قبل الازمه رحنا سرقنا القمح
لنجوع المدنيين هايبارته رحنا سرقنا النفط
لنجمد المدنيين هي عبارته
يا اخي لحظه لحظه عن رئيس النظام رئيس
النظام المشكله اللي هو عم يقول لك انا عم
بعمل هيك بتقول لي رئيس النظام مش لان
يعني النظام او ضده في وقائع على الارض هو
بيعترف لك فيها بيقول لك احنا بدنا نكسرهم
ليفه بمقابله على الروسيه على القناه
الروسيه رئيس الوزراء السوري بيقول اكبر
خطر الرئيس الاسد انه ما عمل سلام معنا
واشنطن بيقول ينقل عشره هو عباره عن
الرئيس دبليو بوش بيقول انا اردت ان يفهم
الاسد انه طريق اوروبا واشنطن لن تمر الا
عبر العلياء
الذي يعاني الازمه في سوريا اسرائيليه
الازمه الاساسي كل الازمه بالمنطقه كلها
الحصار اللي مضروب الخانق على كل هذه
الدول مين اللي محاصره امريكا اي مؤسسه
بالعالم عندنا بده يجيبه بالنفط ممنوع
ممنوع مين ممنوع وشركه الفرنسيه انا بدي
اطلع من عنديتك روح على اوروبا
المانيا التي تعتبر رابع او خامس اقتصاد
على مستوى العالم رئيس البرلمان الالماني
باسبوعين الماضي بيقول في خوف من المانيا
ههه
بهذا
[موسيقى]
الموضوعات العرب
تكلم سفيره قال له كلمت جماعتنا هذا عطينا
القمر انه يسبهم والمؤامره الى غير ذلك
لكن حقيقه انت تعتقد ان اوروبا ستفلس
سيرفا انقلابات بالمؤسسات هذا مستحيل اول
ما اقول لك الله يبارك فيك
شمال افريقيا يزحف الان يعني قوارب الموت
رايحه على اوروبا لماذا لان اوروبا هي
الوطن البديل الممكن لهؤلاء
انا موجود هناك ولا افكر في الرجوع مطلقا
ولا يهمك انا عارف حقوق وواجبات وما
يوافره لا نجوع هناك على الاقل اوطاننا
اصبح بلا كرامه لا يمكن له اما انه النظام
يضع نفسه في موضوع الضحيه وان يتهم
الاخرين بالمؤامره لكي يغطي على فشله
امريكا
ما تبحث عن ذلك تبحث عن هذا لكي تغطي على
فشلها لكن لا يستقيل هو لا يقول انا هو
مستعد مدمر البلد من اجل شخص واحد شخص
يدمر البلد وي السكان اللي فيه وجههم لكي
يبقى هو في السلطه المساله هي مساله
عصابات وعائلات تحكم المنطقه العربيه
لديها مصالح ولديها اراضي وعقارات واموال
ومليارات مستعده تحرق اوطانها تجوع الشعوب
وتبقى في السلطه الدليل على ذلك ان هذه
العائلات الحاكمه والتي راكم الاستعمار
وجوده هي المتسببه في هذه الكارثه اعتقد
ان النظام العالمي اين اتفق معك استاذنا
النظام العالمي يمكن ان يمنع وصول المنطقه
العربيه الى حاله كبرى من الايرانيات يعني
مقبول للمواطن ان يجوع لكن لا الى مرحله
الثوره ويشبع دون ان يبلغ مرحله الواحد
هذا هو هو ان تبقى هذه المنطقه كطار
محميات يعني يمكن ان يعيش فيها المواطن
ونحن نتحكم في ذلك هي السوق لنا سوق
الامكانيه الدليل على ذلك لانه في دول
خليجيه نجحت في انها تخرج من هذا الطور
توافقت مع الامريكان هذه الدبلوماسيه دون
ان يدمر لي بلدي ماذا فعل صدام حسين بيه
يعني سنلقي بهم في البحر على عبد الناصر
الى اين ذهبت مصر طز في امريكا سوريا الى
غير ذلك لكن هو يتغطى بالخارج لكي يغطي
على فشله الداخلي لان من يقول المسؤوليه
عندي سيحاسب وعندما يكون هناك فصل للسلطات
وقضاء عادل يمكن ان يحاسب ليست لدينا
ثقافه المحاسبات لكن لو مكروه غدا سرق
اموال في فرنسا او دمر مؤسسات فرنسيه يمكن
ان يوضع في السجن يعني ليست لدينا هذه
الثقافه عربي كمن ثقافه الاستبداد الى ان
تحول حتى داخل الشعوب واخطر من الى ثقافه
طبيعيه يعني بالنسبه الينا من ليس لديه
واسطه لا يستطيع ان يعيش مهما بلغت كفاءته
الدكاتره والمهندسين والاطباء يبيعون
شاورما ويبيعه يعني كبده يعني هذا ما حدث
عندنا وصلت عائلات متنفذه ومجموعات من
اللصوص تحرس وانظر اعلاميه وكانوا الديني
لابقاء الوضع كمان
دكتور يعني انت كل شيء همم محاصره وحصار
وضغوط ومؤامره والى معانا لك دكتور انت
تعلم ان بلادنا والكثير من الانظمه وصلت
اليها المليارات من المساعدات يا رجل في
سوريا اليوم حتى المساعدات التي تصل الى
الجوعه داخل سوريا تباع في السوق السوداء
عبر مافيات النظام عبر النظام النظام في
سوريا اليوم النظام في سوريا يبيع
الكهرباء بالدولار للاردن ولبنان ويضع
المليارات والملايين هو وزوجته وغيره في
بنوك خارجيه البنزين في سوريا اليوم سعر
لتر البنزين في سوريا اليوم 25,000 ليره
والمازوت مفقود والناس تموت من البرد هناك
بنزين وهناك مازوت لكنه بيد النظام بيد
العصابه هل يعقل ان البنك المركز السوري
يا دكتور عبد اللقيس ليس فيه دولار واحد
بينما حسابات بشار وبقيه العصابه اكثر من
300 مليار حسب التقارير السويسريه خارج
سوريا طيب عندكم في كم مليار عندكم في
لبنان عندكم في لبنان
الكم حوت هذول اللي يسيطرون على الساحه
تقدر تعدل لي مليارات وفي سويسرا وخارج
سويسرا اذا كان هذا الحاجه اللي تفضلت في
النهار المليارات هن حاطينهم بره ليش ما
بيصدروا لهم اياهم ويعلن عن هذه الحسابات
جهارا من قبل هذه الناس اللي هي بسويسرا
وبغيرها وبيقولوا انه هذا له هالادم
طيب هذا انا مش عم ادافع عن حدا من هون
ولا من هون لكن وقت اللي لحد
هلال الموانئ الى سوريا
عفوا شويه ياسر هذه الدول لانه هي
المتامره لان هن ما بيتحرك دولار واحد
وانت بتعرفها طبعا دولار واحد من مائل ما
بتحرك الا ما بده يمرق عبر نيويورك
طبعا لو هنا
مساهمين لهذا العمل كيف تتحول هاي
المليارات الدولارات وما بينكشف عنها
ان هؤلاء وكلاء المشروع الخارجي
[موسيقى]
يعني من بعد الحرب العالميه الثانيه القوه
الغربيه
عندي ازرع لي وكلاء هؤلاء يقومون بالمهمه
باقل الدكتور لا لا لا لا هو لا يتدخل متى
يتدخل الجيش الامريكي في العراق وفي اليمن
عندما يتم تحريك معاهدات سايكس بيكو يتم
تحريك الحدود صدام حسين دخلوا عليه لما
دخل على الكويت يعني حرك سيكس فيكو حرك
الاتفاقيات ياتون لكن دون ذلك لا يتحركون
اللحظه فقدان الثروات التي يحتاجها
الاوروبي من الجزائر تصل على طبق من ذهب
التي يحتاجها في كل مكان تذهب اليه
حث لك عليه في الوضع الاقتصادي النخب
والاحزاء يعني
ماذا تفعل تتحرر من هذا المنوال لم يتحرر
انا احميه انا عندي عميل لازم احميه
يشتغلني ليش احفيه لكن المشكله
داخل لاني دوري انا دوري انا هو انا انزع
هذا النظام ان ادمر هذا النظام لماذا لانه
سيدمرني هذا النظام الان يدمر نفسه ياكل
نفسه يعني النظام الان
العربي سي
نتهي احتلال مره اخرى يعني الناس لا تريد
ان تفهم انه ال- ال- القوه الاجنبيه
الخارجيه الفرنسيه الامريكيه الالمانيه
الروسيه تقوم بدورها كقوه مهينه في العالم
لماذا لا تحتل اليابان لانه ما عنده
قابليه لانه يحتل نحن عندنا القضيه
الاحتلال مجموعه الصعاليك اللي يحكموا في
هذه الجمهوريات هو كلام انا معك انه كلام
لكن لا يتامرون عليه هو جزء من اللعبه
الطاغيه جزء من المشروع طيب وليس متامر
بقول لك الدكتور يقول لك هو يقاوم هو ضد
هو الجماعه
بسبب المقاومه الرئيس بشار الاسد
يقول لك نحن عم نعمل هيك بسبب هذا المشروع
الرئيس الصهيوني يقول لك نحنا
يا اخي يا اخي
لو جاء منه ليش عامل يحاربوه
لك يا اخي هم يدمروا سوريا
هم ان يحول سوريا الى مشروع عراقي اخر ثم
حلتهم لو ارادوه يفعلوا له مثل صدام
يخرجوهم الحفره يعني هم يريدون بقاء هذا
الطاغيه لان دوره وهو تدمير البلد ولا
رايح فين البلد
وبشار الاسد لكن في يوم وليله ياتون به
مثل ما فعله
لو كان ما جاء 20 رئيس في امريكا
لا يجب ان يرحل على بكره
عم بقول لك الدكتور انه انت انت الان
لماذا وصلنا الى هنا لماذا وصلنا الى هنا
انت تعلم الاردن
كل فتره حرارت
باسقاط الرؤوس الكبيره دقيقه مصر الان
دخلت غرفه الانعاش بيقول لك من يدخل غرفه
انعاش صندوق النقد الدولي لا يخرج منها
حيا طيب ماشي لبنان انت عارف اليمن انت
عارف السودان طب انا بدي اسالك قيس سعيد
في تونس ماذا قدم للتونسيين بعد خمسه سنه
ولا اكثر سنه اكثر من سنه دقيقه
ليش بده ما يقدروا يقف على درايفر ما تصدق
في رئيس بتدعم الحياه
الامريكيه وبيسقط الرئيس اللي بيدعموهن
مثل بشار
اقوى من امريكا
اقوى من كل شيء هو قوي جدا
في تحالف كبير مش انه هو
تحالف مع هو عنده روسيا وعنده ايران دقيقه
دقيقه دقيقه كم كان سعر الطونان الايراني
الايراني قبل ثلاثه اشهر 25000 قديش الان
60 الاف
ايرانيين اموالهم وكل العملات الصعبه
المتوفره لدى الشعب الايراني تهرب الى
الخارج الان مين يدخل الامريكي صحيح انه
في هذا رجل الايراني
الدولار اليوم الدولار اليوم اكثر من 40
45,000 تومان الليره السوريه حول
اللبنانيه حوالي 50,000 ليره الدينار
العراقي حول 1600 والريال اليمني همم
السؤال المطروح سؤال المطروح لماذا لا
نحمل الجوع في ايران والفقر في سوريا
والفقر في اليمن والفقر في لبنان والسودان
وتونس ومصر والجزائر وكل هذه الدول لماذا
تذهب وتقول لبره الخارجي
مقدمات صغيره وبصير تتكبر وبتضخم وفي
استغلال كبير لا لها من الخارج عندنا
منظمات السفيره الامريكيه بتقول بدها تعمل
هلا ب 25 مليار مليون دولار كل شهر
دفعنا 10 مليار دولار
بس قبل حتى قبل ما تلمع زيك قبل ما تلمع
صورتها الدكتور في العراق العراق
ميزانيه العراق
135 مليار سنويا رصده اكثر من 35 مليار من
اجل الكهرباء حتى هذه اللحظه ليس هناك في
العراق
ايران هذه الاموال اذا ايران حميتهم وهي
امويلهم وائل مش بره ليش ما بيصاد روحوا
بيقولوا هذه لهم طيب ماشي جميل جدا
الدكتور جميل دكتور دكتور
الاساسيه من اللحميها السفير الامريكي جدا
من لبنان
يا اخي في لبنان كارثه اجتماعيه ومعيشيه
غير مسبوقه تصور الشعب اللبناني العظيم
يعيش الان معظموا على المساعدات وينتظر
السلال او السلع الغذائيه صح ولا لا طيب
الرجل القادم من لبنان ويقل يا اخي
هؤلاء الحيتان او هذا النظام الذي يجوع
اللبنانيين ويقتل اللبنانيين ويهجر
اللبنانيين عم يعطيك عم بيقول لك في غرفه
عمليات امريكيه اييه تدير كل هذه اللعبه
في لبنان في العراق لماذا فعلوا كل ذلك في
العراق لماذا الان الدينار العراقي
بدايتها هوى لماذا
اليس اليس بسبب التدخل الامريكي
والمؤامرات الغربيه
يعني بالنسبه لانك تضع كله على الامريكان
يعني تخرج من المسؤوليه يعني
موجوده غرف العمليات موجوده لاي دوله هذا
دور المخابرات الخارجيه في كل دوله هناك
مكتب يرعى هذه المنطقه في مناطق قابله
لذلك وفي مناطق غير قابله
في دول قابله وفي دول غير قابله يعني هناك
دول غير قابل ذلك
او ما هو الممانعه وخاصه الدول التي وضعت
عليها لم تدخل ايران دخل كل العواصم
العربيه دمر اليمن دمروهم عن طريق جوعا
وقتها
يعني الجماعه بالنسبه لبغداد تعرف ماذا
فعلوا كم قتلوا وهجروا ودمروا في العراق
واستغل الايرانيون الفرصه لوضع يده على
العراق
المافيا التي لا تتبع ايراف في العراق
الامريكي يراقب هو على ابار النفط على
ثروات معينه لكن يترك دمار المنطقه
الاقليم الاطماع الاقليميه الايرانيه ثم
فساد منتخب العراقي لا يمكن ان تصدق حجم
المليارات التي سرقها العراقيون اساس
العراقيون ونقابهم من الميزانيه العراقيه
رغم كل الثروات انظر ماذا يحدث في ليبيا
من الذهب انظر ماذا يحدث للجزائر في تونس
بس بصراحه تصير مثل لبنان كيف يعني
مرحله من الاجتماع لا يمكن فيه لا رئيس
ولا معارضه ولا احزاب ان تنقذ الموقف
الجميع اذا لم يتفق الجميع
نفاد المواد الاساسيه امواج الهجره
الهاربه عبر البحار يعني وضع اقتصادي
كارثي نحن على حفى كارثه
السبب هو عصابات الداخل التي اكلت الاخضر
هذه العصابات لم يتم محاسبته لم يمسك فاسد
الطيبه للرئيس المستقي يسعد لك لم يحاسب
فاسدون لم يحدث تطهير حقيقي لشبكات الفساد
التحتيه التي خربت الاقتصاد وانها بتقول
كل شيء يعني اذا لم يتم التخلص من هذه
الشبكات التي تملك كل شيء في الاقتصاد وهي
نافذه وتتحرك طبعا بحمايه اجنبيه فانه لا
يمكن الرغم ذلك يعني اما الفساد ان ينتصر
او ان تنتصر الدوله طيب خليني اسالك سؤال
بس قصير يعني تستطيع ان تقول بان كل هذا
الدمار والجوع والفقر والتهجير والكوارث
الاجتماعيه والمعيشيه في هذه البلدان
العربيه ما عدا دول الخليج سببها ان هذه
الدول لم يعد هناك دول بالمعنى الحقيقي
للكلمه اصبحت عباره عن عصابات ومافيات
تتاجر بكل شيء كما يفعل بشار في سوريا
يتاجر بكل شيء يتاجر
بالبنزين يتاجر بالكهرباء يتاجر بكل شيء
وفي تونس نفس العمليه
الجزائر كله السودان الاردن
مساله وقت هذه الدول ستنهار جميعها هي
مساله وقت لماذا لان في نهايه المطاف
الفاسدون لن يجدوا ما ياكلوه الا اكل
بعضهم البعض يعني سينتهي المساله ما يحدث
في تونس الان هو انه سرقوا كل شيء تقريبا
انهارت المقدره الشرائيه الجزائر رغم كل
الثروات لكن العصابات الموجوده هناك اكلت
تقريبا الاخضر واليابس انظر الى ليبيا
انظر الى مصر المنطقه هذه لديه خصوصيه
باستثناء الخصوصيه المشرقيه الفساد اكل كل
شيء هناك يعني ما يحدث الان هو اما ان
تقام حرب حقيقيه على الفساد وتحاسب
على ذلك ستنهار هذه الدول ان لم تنقذ
نفسها بحروب على الفساد فساد على الفساد
على المحاكرين المضاربين يعني الموظفون
الاشباح هناك الاف الموظفين الاشباح في
الاداره الاداره العربيه يعني موظف موجود
ياخذ راتب لكنه لم يذهب يوما الى العمل
يعني هناك كوارث كبيره جدا داخل الدور
اعاده هيكله دون مشروع اقتصادي حقيقي دون
عمليه انقاذ لا يتم فيها انقاذ الفرد او
النظام لكن انقاذ الجماعه فاننا سنذهب الى
ما لا يحمد عقبه وستنهار هذه الدول وتتحول
الى محميه اقليميه للمشروع الصفوي او
الصهيوني او الامريكي او الاوروبي او
الصيني او الروسي او غيره مثل ما يحدث في
العراق في سوريا
بس دكتور طيب لماذا انت لا تنظر الى
الصوره الاكبر الى الى حد ما تركيه تركيه
تعاني من اكبر نسبه تضخم في تاريخها راح
يوصل 100% التبخر وتركيا يعني رغم كل
انجازاته الان على كف عفريت من الناحيه
الاقتصاديه والمعيشيه الليره التركيه كانت
قبل سنوات بليرتين وقبل الدولار الان
الليره التركيه ب 16 ليره والرواتب على
حاله ايران دوله اقليميه كبرى دوله عظيمه
بغض النظر استقبلها ماشي ايران تنهار من
الداخل
وبدا الجوع بس هذا لين في انه ايران على
كف عفريت الان من اقصاها الى اقصاها طيب
ايران تركيا بدي اسالك سؤال غيره يا رجل
لماذا تتجاهل يا دكتور محمد ما فعلته
جائحه كورونا بالعالم اجمع وليس بالدول
العربيه ليش حاطط راسك براس سوريا
المسكينه اللي خرجت من من حرب طاحنه ومن
لبنان والسودان وتونس هذه بلدان بالاصل
مغلوب على امرها اوروبا الان انظر كيف
يسقط اليورو امام الدولار كيف يسقط الجنيه
الاسترليني امام الدولار انت ليش متعجب
انه يسقط الجنيه المصري او تسقط الليره
اللبنانيه او يسقط تسقط الليره السوريه او
الدينار العراقي او الطومان الايراني او
الليره التركيه او الريال اليمني او او
جاوبني انا عندما يكون عندك اقتصاد عندما
يكون عندك اقتصاد دوله حقيقيه في منطقه
السياده يعني عندك تصنيع انت تجد هذه
الصناعه فرنسيه صناعه المانيه يابانيه
تركيه الى غير ذلك فلا خوف عليك تمر بازمه
هناك فرق بين ان تصيب الانسان حمى عرضيه
وتمر وبين عافاكم الله ان يصيبه سرطان مع
ان نحن سرطان داخل الخلايا تقتل بعضها
البعض ما يحدث في ايران انها مستهدفه صحيح
ككل الدول تركيا مستهدفه ككل الدول الصين
كل دوله مستهدفه لكن هناك حزام احزمه امان
بالنسبه للاقتصاد هناك اقتصاد حقيقي هناك
فصل السلطات هناك مجتمع مدني هناك احزاب
هناك برلمان هناك دستور هناك نخب وطنيه
حقيقيه هذا لا نملك نحن لا نصنع شيء هل
وجد في يدك يوما هاتف صناعه عربيه يعني
قلم يعني اي شيء لا عندنا فنحن ما تنسى
نفسنا كل الطاقه يعني ناكل خزانات النفط
والغاز اللي عندنا ثم بعد ذلك نجوع لنعود
لنشعه القوى العالميه هذا صنعناه بانفسنا
ان نحن لم نقل ان هذه حقيقتنا عاريه ولابد
ان نخرج منها هذه المرحله لنصنع مثل الامم
الاخرى ونصبح مثل الايراني مثل التركي مثل
الفرنسي مثل الالماني ونحن قادرون على ذلك
ورايت ماذا صنعت قطر في كاس العالم وما
احد ذلك من رجه في الخارج وتكلم عليها
الجميع بسبب النجاح عندما نجح يعادينا
الجميع يعني هذا نجاح لنا قادرون عليه
بالفعل ان نحن لم نفعل ذلك وبقينا في
مساله هذا قومي هذا اخواني هذا ارهابي هذا
كذا فسنبقى نتقاتل ونتناحر حته تنقذ علينا
بقيت اذا التفريق بين السياق الاوروبي
والسياق الايراني والتركي والعربي هو
سياقات مختلفه انه مختلفه مختلفه تماما
هذه هذه للدكتور انت دكتور لماذا تخلط زيت
بعبيد اذا سحب تعبير خلت المثال الاوروبي
مختلف عن الامثله العربيه انت انت تقول لي
الان اوروبا ستسقط وارتبه تعاني واوروبا
كذا وعم بتصور لي بريطانيا مثل لبنان وعم
بتصور
لفرنسا فرنسا
اللي موجود بالعالم كان اسقطت اسقطت
النظام الاحادي الى غير رجعه من شان هيك
انت بتعيش بعالم في فوضى ما في شوف لي
مؤسسه مجلس الامن هلا بعد فيها طلع قرار
هلا بتلجا امريكا للمؤسسات الامميه اللي
بعيده وارجع لي الموضوع الاقتصادي في
اوروبا
سببه الحصار الامريكي على بلادنا منعم
دافع عن انظمه فيس زي هون ولا هونكه يعني
عندما تسقط العملات دكتور عندما تنهار
العمله عندما تنهار العمله في لبنان في
سوريا في ايران في تركيا في اليمن اه في
الجزائر في مصر في في يا دكتور انت خبير
اقتصادي انت تعلم
الاقتصادات القويه هي التي تحمي عمولاتها
هي التي تحمل عمولات يعني احنا نشتكي
دائما من الدولار الدولار
يا اخي الدولار لا يرتفع الدولار الدولار
المشكله المشكله بان في سوريا
يبقى هناك اي مصدر مصدر انتاج بسبب الفساد
المصدر الوحيد اللي شغال في سوريا هو مصدر
الكابتاجون للعصابه الحكمه وعلى راسها
بشار
ترجع بتروحله بتكون بتنقل لمحاله
كيف بترجع بنحكي بالقصه الفساد اللي موجود
ببلادنا موجود الا بحمايه الامريكان لدشنه
بكل دقيقه دقيقه
كل دول العالم
هذه الاقتصادات في كامل المنطقه التي
تستطيع ان تحمي عمولاتها نحن
كل كلامنا الجنيه الاسترليني عفوا الجنيه
المصري صارب 34 جنيه مقابل الدولار والحبل
على الجرار الليره اللبنانيه 50,000
السوريه 7000 الطومان الايراني 60,000
والايراني طيب لو عندك اقتصاد قوي انا بدي
اسالك انت قبل شوي قلت لك لماذا لم ينهر
الروبل الروسي لانه الدوله
الروسيه 17 مليون كلما عنده يعني من
الامكانيات الهيلي وهي دوله عظمى ما انا
محاصره يعني مش محاصره
الحصان
لانه هي عندها بنيه هائله جدا يعني
المنطقه يعني
بس انت بتقبلها والله انه راتب المواطن
السوري يكون 13$
عم يقول لك 12 دولار بالشهر طيب سنه
للسنوات
اللي حاطط يده على النفط السوري بالشمال
مين اللي سرقه
يا دكتور
انت تتحدث عن النفط السوري وكانه يقف وراء
الازمه المعيشي
يا دكتور انت تعلم النفط السوري لم يدخل
منه قرش واحد الى الميزانيه السوريه منذ
50 عاما كان طولنا كل عمره يقولوا لنا
اموال النفط السوري في اياد امينه طلع في
ايادي ابي ساعه
وقت الليل لو انه النفط السوري كان مسروق
كيف كانت عيش سوريا وما عندها صفر مديونيه
كيف كان عندها سفر مديونيه لو ما كان
عندها هذا الانتاج الداخلي بس هلا كل يوم
100 سنه امريكا
الى تركيا كل شيء
عصابات
كل نحن بلبنان وطلعوا اللحظه شويه عليه
سوريا الى وضع خاص كان لبنان المحيط مع
الاردن مع العراق مع تركيا كل هذا الاطراف
عيش على الاقتصاد السوري وكانوا كلهم
مرتاح بس بدي اسالك سؤال بدي اسالك سؤال
لماذا تهرب من انه هناك دول معينه في
المنطقه حتى لك اياها هذه دول اصبحت الدول
فاشله دول عصابات ومافيات كل ما يقع تحت
ما يسمى بمحور الممانعه والمقاومه
اليس من المضحك ان ترى هادول تبع الممانعه
والمقاوله وما بعرف شو وكده يريدون تحرير
المواطن الفلسطيني
راتبه 700$ قدرات بالسوري على 9.000 مره
اكثر من لبنان على 200 مره
لحظه شويه ليش فلسطين عايشين ليش فلسطين
من الجوع هذا الموضوع الاحتلال الصهيوني
الى فلسطين لا يقارن اذا انه بده يتحرر
هذا الموضوع بالمستوى المعيشي اللي
عايشينها السكان وشو عيش سكان اهل غزه كيف
عايشين احسن من المليار
دو تونسي
وتتعامل يعني مع المساعدات بشكل شفاف حتى
المساعدات حتى المساعدات التي تاتي الى
سوريا
بالسوق السوداء والامر الاخر انا قلت لك
المليارات الان الناس لبعض يطالب اين
مليارات الخليج لماذا لا تاتي هذا الايام
مليارات الخليج راحت على مصر وين اختفت
مليارات اللي بتجيء على سوريا مربع في
المليارات اللي بتجيء على سوريا بده
يستفيد منها محمود
كان في فلسطين لو كان جيش عربي في فلسطين
جيش السوري او المص- لقبادهم اذا كانت لهم
انتهى الوقت
نحن في بدايه العام 23 انت اين ترى العالم
العربي ذاهب على ضوء هذا الانهيار المعيشه
بجمله واحده
طالما هذه الاداره الامريكيه بعد متسلطه
على هذا العالم بهذا الطريقه عملت زيد
الوضع سوء لكن انا اقول انه هذا النظام
الاحادي هو بدا بالانهيار وسوف العربيه
انهيار القطب الاحادي الى غير رجعه والناس
بترد عليك للاسف الشديد عيشه قديش كيف ترد
يا دكتور
سنذهب الى اسوا سينا 21 23 اما ان تستعيد
كرامتها بالوسائل المتاحه لان هذا النظام
سيبيعها هي و سياخذ اول طائره نحو الاموال
التي وضعتها العصابات في البنوك الخارجي
والدكتور محمد
المقبل فحتى ذلك الحين هو فيصل قاسم
نحييكم من الدوحه الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]